thank you so much for coming so my
question is that for the elie wiesel
foundation basically there was the
Madoff Ponzi scheme which caused it to
lost almost all of its assets and so my
question is like how has this affected
the operations of the foundation and
also one comment that means mr. Wiesel
made was that banks can be bailed out
like automobile companies been bailed
out there may be foundation sometimes
should be bailed out as well in certain
circumstances like this so I was
wondering what you make of that
statement and also what do you think is
the role of foundations in today's
society and economy thank you you've
done your research in terms of
foundations needing to be bailed out or
the role of foundations I find I always
try to focus on what's the purpose of
the foundation we're here to serve whom
are we serving whom are we attempting to
serve those people deserve to be helped
and if they're worthy of being helped
whatever mechanisms whether its funding
a foundation volunteering your time
let's help people who are less fortunate
than ourselves the role of foundation i
think is method of organization to be
able to provide that service what do you
think you ask the question you thought
about it so i think that foundations
itself like it has a you know it has an
important role in helping organizations
do the work that they want to accomplish
at the same time they also have a
financial responsibility to its donors
which I find it's like an interesting
tension so say if it wasn't the Madoff
Ponzi scheme but it was the financial
crisis that cost you know the foundation
to lose its assets or it was some kind
of mismanagement of money how would you
feel that
I think foundations are endowed with
public trust we have a phenomenal
obligation to the donors the recipients
the foundation itself I reengaged with
Professor Wiesel after I read about the
Foundation's loss in the madoff scandal
and I basically knew the great work that
he was doing in the world and offered to
volunteer my time to be able to help him
I believe this is the air from smallest
to the largest foundations there's a
difference between an investment in
financial markets that might go up and
down and the type of concentration of
financial assets that many foundations
did one of the reasons why I'm so proud
to be part of what you're doing is a
class studying philanthropy studying
best practice would be hopefully to
avoid those types of investment
decisions in the future